les touristes eux reprennent
tranquillement leurs droits ou
centre-ville d'ottawa des cinq clichés
mais attendue depuis longtemps par
l'industrie touristique
et pour s'assurer que des affaires
reprennent l'industrie attendait aussi
des assouplissements mesures sanitaires
aujourd'hui nous pouvons annoncer des
ajustements à nos mesures sanitaires
parce que les canadiens se sont
mobilisés pour se protéger à compter de
lundi prochain plus besoin d'être
vaccinés pour prendre un avion ou un
train au canada et
pour réduire les files d'attentes dans
les aéroports ottawa met fin à
l'obligation vaccinale pour tous ceux
qui travaillent et nous allons à
maintenir comme il se doit les mesures
pour les voyageurs internationaux cela
veut dire que deux doses de vaccin
seront toujours exigée pour franchir la
frontière même chose pour les canadiens
qui rentre à la maison sans quoi une
quarantaine leur sera imposé il s'agit
selon la santé publique d'une mesure à
la fois efficace et peu coûteuse
l'association du transport aérien du
canada se réjouit sans rien tenir pour
acquis c'est un retard surtout peu près
tout le monde nous partenaires
économiques oui
comme le gouvernement demeure encore en
retard en ce 4 e mandat pour le masquer
la suspension
des procédures actuelles pourraient être
annulés si des petits l'écart monte
chaque only prudent là dessus dans cette
agence de voyage ou si la prudence est
de mise tout comme certains voyages
c'est des bonnes nouvelles mais d'un
autre côté je comprends que certains
voyageurs c'était une sécurité de savoir
que voyager avec des gens qui était veuf
mais comme dans les avions c'est très la
proximité et les longs alors fou
on prend quand même des cli caution le
gouvernement suspend aussi l'obligation
vaccinale pour tous les employés
fédéraux pour le moment et si la mesure
devait être réintroduites à l'automne
ottawa précise que deux doses de vaccin
ce ne serait pas suffisant pour être
considéré adéquatement vacciner et
civelli reggae mach radio canada ottawa